bonsoir et romain rivière merci d'être
avec nous vous faites partie de ces
signataires et vous voyez dans ce retard
de vaccination la preuve donc de la
faillite du modèle de l'union européenne
en quoi les t-il écoutez j'écoutais le
passionnant reportage que vous diffusiez
juste avant cet échange avec vous nous
avons sorti notre livre noir hier et dès
aujourd'hui on voit que des éléments
supplémentaires vient de démontrer la
faillite de la politique menée par
l'union européenne vale neva entreprises
françaises start-up pme et qui réussit à
développer en france un vaccin
on a vu par dogmatisme emmanuel macron a
choisi de ne pas travailler en direct
avec cette entreprise
au contraire du royaume uni qui dès le
mois de juillet dernier investissez
quand on parle de sommes considérables
il faut pas oublier qu'on parle de 100
millions d'euros alors même qu'on
dépense des milliards tous les jours
parce que le pays est fermée donc il
faut mettre ces 100 millions d'euros qui
était une somme importante en rapport
avec les milliards que nous coûte le
fait que nous ayons pas assez de vaccins
emmanuel macron par dogmatisme choisi de
ne pas travailler avec cette entreprise
dit il faut travailler avec l'union
européenne et on voit aujourd'hui après
plus de quatre mois de discussions avec
vale va être obligé de dire balle je ne
peux pas ça ne fonctionne pas on
n'arrive pas à avoir un accord et je
vais travailler avec chacun des pays
comme je lé fais avec le royaume uni
c'est un échec terrible c'est un échec
parce que c'est triste quand même que la
france qui soit l'un des cinq membres du
conseil de sécurité des nations-unies
soit incapable de produire elle-même son
vaccin que la pme
la start up qui pourrait lui permettre
d'être de rentrer de nouveau dans cette
cour des grands pays de recherche
constate qu'elle n'est pas capable de
travailler avec avec la france c'est
extrêmement triste
et tout ça c'est lié au dogmatisme et
cette volonté de tout faire passer par
l'union européenne on vous parlait de
dogmatisme mais at-on le soin quand on a
signé quand on fait partie justement de
l'union européenne est ce qu'on a le
choix de pouvoir s'affranchir de ses
partenaires c'est une bonne question
mais en matière de santé effectivement
nous avions le choix parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une compétence de l'union
européenne il ya des domaines dans
lequel la france a dit je donne cette
compétence à l'union européenne à la
commission pour ce qui est de la santé
ça n'est pas une
ans et donc c'est une volonté en dehors
d'être été affichées par un certain
nombre de dirigeants européens de dire
on donne tout ça là l'union européenne
rien ne nous obligeait à avoir cette
politique c'est simplement pour emmanuel
macron qui essaye d'être le meilleur
élève de l'union européenne l'occasion
de dire écoutez j'en fais plus que les
autres on va encore confié quelque chose
de supplémentaire à cette union
européenne et on voit là qu'en matière
de 2,2 d'achat le le b à ba d'une d'une
organisation communautaire c'est-à-dire
d'être une centrale d'achat l'union
européenne est incapable d'être efficace
elle a été moins efficace on l'a
démontré dans notre livre noir avec
l'ensemble des labos de qu'ils soient
qui sont dans le monde
elle a été moins efficace que le royaume
uni c'est une odieuse machine
administrative qui s'empêtre dans toutes
sortes de contraintes qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les urgences notamment les
urgences de mettre à disposition de ceux
qui le souhaitent des vaccins et cet
échec il est il est terrible parce que
c'est la santé de deux taxes français
2011 pensée qui est en jeu alors il y
avait plusieurs options qui s'offraient
à l'union européenne et au pays est ce
que c'est pas plutôt un mauvais pari
qu'a fait emmanuel macron parce que
cette ce laboratoire y en avait d'autres
et mnm lacroix a fait le choix et le
pari de sanofi qui l'a plutôt louper
c'est pas ça alors y est le problème
écoutez il n'a pas vraiment fait le
choix de sanofi non plus il va il n'a
fait aucun choix français il ay là le
seul choix qui les fait c'est de dire je
confie tout ça à madame von der leyen
présidente de la commission et madame
van der linde ailleurs est venu
l'expliquer à elle s'est plantée il faut
savoir dire les choses
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons dans
une situation désastreuse et nous
courons après l'approvisionnement en
vaccins nous avons besoin est le pire
des choses c'est thierry breton français
commissaire français qui vient nous
annoncer des fausses nouvelles tous les
jours il ait démenti de l' annonce de
nouvelles par la réalité est encore une
fois cette annonce date d'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne n'a pas été capable
de négocier avec la neva et ce
laboratoire renonce c'est tragique
à propos de série breton c'est celui
et affirmer nous n'aurons pas besoin du
spoutnik v le vaccin russe qui a causé
des divisions au sein de l'union
européenne l'allemagne et l'italie
plutôt prompte à collaborer avec la
russie sur ce point beaucoup moins de
volonté du côté français ce sont des
divergences profondes de points de vue
selon vous entre les pays mais
exactement
enfin vous savez c'est charles pasqua
qui autrefois disait ce qu'une nation ne
peut pas faire pour elle personne ne
pourra le faire et la réalité c'est que
à l'occasion de cette crise de la
pandémie due coronavirus et de la course
l'achat de vaccins l'union européenne a
fait la démonstration par l'absurde
qu'elle n'était pas efficace et des pays
un peu plus réaliste que la france je
pense qu'on vous l'évoquiez à l'instant
notamment à l'italie mais ça a été aussi
le cas de la république tchèque de la
hongrie la pologne se sont dit qu'est-ce
qui est disponible aujourd'hui pour
protéger les populations
on a un vaccin en russie qui semble
fonctionner on a des vaccins en chine
qui semble fonctionner on a des vaccins
aux états unis qui fonctionnent ils ont
dit aujourd'hui je vais demander à mon
agences de santé nationales de veiller à
ce que ce vaccin soit utilisé les
mairies de veiller à ce qu'ils soient
bien compatible avec les notions de
santé dont on a besoin et
m'approvisionner là le dogme emmanuel
macron c'est dire non non tant que
l'union européenne n'a pas validé ce
vaccin je l'achèterai pas aujourd'hui on
court après les vaccins cc c'est très
grave ce qui se passe parce qu'en fait
c'est vraiment par up
encore une fois je répète ce mode
dogmatisme parce que s'il n'y a rien
dans la démarche des manuels macron qui
n'est justifiée sur le plan de l'intérêt
de la santé des français
jérôme sa ligne il ya autre chose qui
frappait quand on écoutait les députés
européens sur ce plateau c'est l'opacité
des contrats
est-ce que
vous rassemblement national vous avez
demandé cette levée
voilà enfin plus de transparence sont
ces contrats parce que il me semble qu
aucun député n'a plus jeter un oeil
dessus est ce que c'est normal c'est
effectivement totalement anormal puisque
le rôle d'un parlement qu'il soit
national ou européen c'est de contrôler
justement l'action pour le parlement
européen de la commission et ils ont
refusé de nous donner non seulement
l'accès aux contrats
donc on ne sait pas quel est le quels
sont les termes de la négociation ils
ont refusé de nous donner le nom des
négociateurs vous savez quand on
négocier un contrat c'est important de
savoir qu'ils négocient est-ce que
souvent des gens qui connaissent le
domaine pharmaceutique et ce qu'ils
avaient des intérêts particuliers dans
le cadre de ces négociations
on ne le sait pas ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui entache terriblement le
fonctionnement de la commission et de
l'union européenne et on voit en plus
parce qu'un certain nombre de pays l'ont
révélé qu'ils adhérent des différences
de tarifs qui vont de 1 à 8
c'est à dire que certains vaccins sont
payés huit fois plus cher que les autres
c'est totalement abracadabrantesque on
pourrait à la limite se dire on étudiera
demain comment ça s'est passé
s'il y avait pas la santé des français
qui est en jeu mais aujourd'hui la santé
des français est en jeu il faut arrêter
maintenant de se mettre ce blocage de
l'union européenne merci jérôme rivière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france